what i want to do in this video is order
these fractions from least to greatest
and the easiest way and the what way
that i think we'll we can be sure we'll
get the right answer here is to find a
common denominator because if we don't
find a common denominator these
fractions are really hard to compare
four-ninths versus three-fourths versus
four-fifths eleven twelfths thirteen
fifteenths you can try to estimate them
but what you can get a very you you'll
you'll be able to directly compare them
if you if they all had the same
denominator so the trick here or at
least the first trick here is to try to
find that common denominator and there's
many ways to do it you could just pick
one of these numbers and keep taking
keep taking its multiples and find that
multiple that is divisible by all the
rest another way to do it is look at the
prime factorization of each of these
numbers and then
and then the least common multiple of
them will have to have at least all of
those prime numbers in it it has to be
composed of all of these numbers so
let's do it that second way and then
let's verify that it definitely is
divisible
so nine is the same thing as three times
three so our least common multiple our
least common multiple is going to have
at least one three times three in it
and then four is the same thing as two
times 2 so we're going to also have to
have a 2 times 2 in our prime
factorization of our least common
multiple
5 is a prime number so we're going to
need to have a 5 in there
and then 12
12 and do that in yellow 12 is the same
thing as 2 times 6 which is the same
thing as 2 times 3.
and so in in our least common multiple
we have to have 2 2s but we already have
2 2s right over here from our 4 and we
already have one three we already have
one three right over here another way to
think about it is something that is
divisible by both nine and four is going
to be divisible by 12 because you're
going to have the two twos and you're
gonna have that one three right over
there
and then finally we need to be divisible
by 15 prime factors so let's look at
15's prime factors 15 is the same thing
as 3 times 5. so once again this number
right over here already has a 3 in it
and it already has a 5 in it so we're
cool for 15 for 12 and obviously for the
rest of them so this is our least common
multiple and we can just take this
product
and so this is going to be equal to
3 times 3 is 9. 9 times 2 is 18 18 times
2 is 36 36 times 5 36 times 5. you could
do that in your head if you like but
i'll do it on the side just in case 36
times 5 just so that we don't mess up 6
times 5 is 6 times 5 is 30.
3 times 5 is 15 plus 3
is 180. so our least common multiple is
180. so we want to rewrite all of these
fractions with 180 in the denominator so
this first fraction 4 9
is
what over 180 to go from 9 to 180 we
have to multiply the denominator by 20.
so let me let me do it this way
let me so if we do 4
over 9 to get the denominator of 9 to be
to be 180 you have to multiply it by 20.
and since we don't want to change the
value of the fraction we should also
multiply the 4 by 20.
so we're just really multiplying by 20
over 20 and so 4 9 is going to be the
same thing as 80
80 over
180. now let's do the same thing for
three-fourths
three over 4. well what do we have to
multiply the denominator by to get us to
so it looks like 45 you could divide 4
into 180 to figure that out but if you
take 4 times
4 times 45 4 times 40 is 160 4 times 5
is 20. you add them up you get 180. so
if you multiply the denominator by 45
you also have to multiply the numerator
by 45
3 times 45 is 120 plus 15 so it's 135
135 and the denominator here is 100
180.
now let's do four fifths
four over 5. to get 5 to get to the
denominator to be 180 what do you have
to multiply 5 by
so 5 let's see if you multiply 5 by 30
you'll have you'll get to 150 but you
have to then you have another 30. so you
have to multiply it actually we know it
right over here if you multiply it by 36
multiply by 36 well then you have to
multiply the numerator by 36 as well and
so our denominator is going to be 180
our numerator 4 times 30 is 120 4 times
6 is 24 so it's 144
over 180
and then we have only two more to do
so we have our 11 12
11 over 12
is so to get the denominator to be 180
we have to multiply 12 by
so 12 times 10 is 120 and then you have
60 left so you have to multiply it by
15.
15 in the denominator and 15 in the
numerator and so this gives us the
denominator gives us 180 and 11 times
15. so 10 times 15 is 150 and then you
have one more 15 so it's going to be 165
and then finally we have 13 15.
we have 13
13 15. to get to our denominator to be
180 you have to multiply it by 12. we
already figured out that 12 times 15 is
180 so multiply it by 12 that will give
us 180 in the denominator and so you
have to also multiply the numerator by
12 so that we don't change the value of
the fraction we know 12 times 12 is 144.
you put one more 12 in there you get
156 and do that right 12 plus 144 is
going to be 156. so we've rewr written
each of these each of these fractions
with a new with that new common
denominator of 180 and now it's very
easy to compare them you really just
have to look at the numerators
so the smallest of the numerators is
this 80 right over here so 4 9 is the
smallest
4 9 is the least of these numbers so let
me just write it over here so this is
our ordering we have 4 9 comes first
which is the same thing as 80 over 180
let me write it both ways
80 over 180 then the next smallest
number looks like it's this 135 right
over here so then our next one is going
to be the 135 i want to do that same
color
the next one is going to be that 1
over 180 which is the same thing as
three-fourths which is the same thing as
three-fourths and then the next one is
going to be let's see we have the 144
over 180.
so this is going to be the 144 over 180
which is the same thing as four-fifths
and then finally or we actually have two
more the next is this 156 over 180
so then we have our 156
over 180 which is the same thing as 13
13 over 15 and then we have one left
over the 165 over 180 which is the same
thing so we i want to do that in yellow
we have our 165 over 180 which is the
same thing as 11 12 which is the same
thing as 11 12. and we're done we have
finished we have finished our ordering
so this is
if you're doing the khan academy module
on this you would this is what you would
input into into that little box there